♪ ♪
>> THE MEXICAN BORDER IS VERY
UNPROTECTED BY OUR LAWS.
WE HAVE HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE AND
VERY UNSAFE LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT HOPEFULLY SOON.
HOPEFULLY CONGRESS WILL GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER AND GET IN
AND CREATE SOME VERY POWERFUL
LAWS, LIKE MEXICO HAS, AND LIKE
CANADA HAS, AND LIKE ALMOST ALL
COUNTRIES HAVE.
WE DON'T HAVE LAWS.
WE HAVE CATCH AND RELEASE.
YOU CATCH AND YOU IMMEDIATELY
RELEASE AND PEOPLE COME BACK
YEARS LATER FOR A COURT CASE
EXCEPT THEY VIRTUALLY NEVER COME
BACK.
SO WHAT WE ARE PREPARING FOR
COME OF THE MILITARY TO SECURE
OUR BORDER BETWEEN MEXICO AND
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE A MEETING ON IT IN A
LITTLE WHILE WITH GENERAL MATTIS
AN END I THINK THAT IT IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DO.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESPONDING TO A QUESTION ABOUT
HIS PLANTERS AND NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS IN THE MILITARY TO
PROTECT OUR SOUTHERN BORDERS.
HERE WITH REACTION, AND OUR ATB
CONTRIBUTOR, FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT DAN
BONGINO.
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGY SEBASTIAN GORKA.
AUTHOR OF THE BRAND-NEW
SOON-TO-BE "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER, "THIS BHO," A
MEMOIR, AND I HAD THE HONOR OF
HOSTING A PARTY FOR GERALDO,
EVEN THOUGH WE DISAGREE WITH
THIS ISSUE COME UP CORRESPONDENT
AT LARGE GERALDO RIVERA.
ALL RIGHT, GERALDO, IF YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE A CARAVAN OF
PEOPLE PLANNING TO CONFRONT
BASICALLY EVERY BORDER AGENT,
THIS IS NOW A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREATS.
EVERY AGENT WILL BE AT RISK.
MEXICO IS ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN WHEN THEY USUALLY JUST
THROW PEOPLE IN CENTRAL AMERICA
OUT OR IN JAIL.
AND IF MEXICO DOES THIS, THEY
ALLOW THIS, THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS AT THE
BORDER IF PEOPLE BECOME VIOLENT
IN MY OPINION.
YOUR REACTION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU ARE NOT
PROMOTING A CIVIL WAR, OTHERWISE
HE WOULDN'T BE FRIENDS WITH ME.
>> Sean: [LAUGHS]
>> I EMBRACE YOUR GRACIOUS
GENEROSITY AND YOUR HOSPITALITY
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PARTY.
>> Sean: WE HAD THE BEST TIME,
THANK YOU.
>> I JUST THINK THAT THIS WHOLE
STORY OF THE CARAVAN IS
TREMENDOUSLY HYPED.
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS, THIS
GROUP, PEOPLE WITHOUT BORDERS,
HAS BEEN ORGANIZING THIS EASTER
TIME MARCHES TO DEMONSTRATE THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMELANDS, IN THIS CASE,
HONDURAS, TO FLEE AND THEY WANT
A REGULATED APPROACH.
THEY WANT MORE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
AND ALL THE REST OF IT.
THIS CARAVAN WAS LARGER THAN
MOST OF THEM.
BUT IT'S 1,000 MILES FROM THE
U.S. BORDER.
IT'S ALREADY COME AS YOU SAID,
BREAKING UP, THE CARAVAN IS
DISBANDING.
>> Sean: ONLY BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT PARKED IN MEXICO,
THOUGH.
>> WELL, IT COULD BE, BECAUSE --
BUT THE WOMEN AND CHILDREN THAT
COMPRISE MOST OF THIS GROUP,
THEY HAD NO OF GETTING TO THE
U.S. BORDER.
THEY HAVE NO MONEY, THEY ARE
FLEEING SOME SEVERE ECONOMIC
REPRESSION.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, IF THEY
DON'T STOP THIS AND THAT GROUP